heute ist der ersten sechster der fuel
und ich sind ein jahr zusammen und ich
überrascht wie mit weise wollen wir
fliegen und kann die eltern eine seele
mit oliven oder mit käse kaufen
ich kannte er schon mal sagen oder weiß
auch wir sind ja nicht langweilig
sondern ein paar tage also ich glaube
jetzt nicht dass wir nach amerika oder
nach japan fliegen und fliegen wir
richtig der mensch mit
der typ der gerade durch gesagt ist
genau london fliegen also die
überraschung ist es also ein paar snacks
ihr unterwegs eingepackt voll krass
alter auf teneriffa suchen jetzt nach
aliens er könnte sandra einfach mal mit
den kommunizieren
sie soll das hat eine auf meinen tisch
gesessen
in der alter schwede ist das eine lange
schlange reardon im auto und bin hier
den london
dann mache ich immer so denn vom bloggen
bin jetzt so richtig in der stadt
angekommen wir konnten leider nicht ins
hotelzimmer jan es ist ja auch gerade
mal 9 uhr da irgendwie sowas ist
eigentlich mittlerweile wo wir
hinfliegen
er werde ich gesagt gar keinen richtigen
plan und suchen jetzt erst mal was zu
fressen der und wann es sind wir so
gesund deger
vitamine hallo ich glaube google street
view
wenn ich jetzt zugute
der typen halte sondern müssten schönes
porträt mitten auf dem asphalt und ich
kann nicht mal einen vernünftigen
greifen damit haben wir keine kamelle
zieren jetzt man bleibt schön findet
vorne noch schöne größte drauf damit man
nicht vergisst man nie verkauft mich
einfach so sonnenbrillen die ich als job
für meine videos benutzen kosten 700
euro ja gar nicht in deutschland
schreibt man einfach einen youtube kanal
bei anderen youtube an unter den videos
in die kommentare und hier in england
ist einfach eine brücke gemeint dass das
brot aus dem lamborghini genau
ich war gerade eigentlich ein schönes
foto vorläufig denn machen dann kam der
schweizer schulklasse also wir machen
das jetzt nochmals
natürlich alter da sind wir einmal in
london am kirchturm eingepackten scheiße
und um ein bisschen haben gerade wieder
eine komplette schulklasse getroffen und
was meint ihr das mädel ist sehr groß
ist er locker 180 ich bin 13 19 meinte
ich habe jetzt 195 fundamente vor wie
man heuer wieder wurde angeschossen
es ist mittlerweile fast halb fünf und
unser zimmer im hotel so immer nicht
fertig deswegen gaben jetzt hier in so
einem park und der typ sitzt einfach im
hohen gras und schilf man jetzt gerade
noch was essen und in dem restaurant
haben die oder ich zeige euch einmal den
clip werde ich auf instagram gepostet
haben und ich habe dem kellner einfach
gerade ganz kurz erwähnt dass wir heute
ein jahrestag haben und dann haben wir
einfach alle diese karte unterschrieben
happy anniversary und zwar so ein dings
gegeben dass judith zwar schnell
aufgegessen hat aber das ist so süß und
dann kommen wir wieder in unser hotel
zimmer rein und die haben einfach hier
auch happy anniversary hin geschrieben
und so eine flasche champagner und rief
also ich hatte wohl lieben aber danke
dafür auch so falls tweed dass die uns
hier was vorbereitet haben
auf dem bett lagen auch so rosen aber
die haben leider das komplette brett
irgendwie zerstört so sah das mit den
rosen hat darauf aus also auch mega dass
unser erster tag london und morgen sehen
wir uns nicht wieder sondern jetzt
sofort diesen tag ist angebrochen
wir freuen uns hier gelten
den herzlichen empfang
bloß jule steigenden taxi ein wow golden
gate bridge juristische sieht einfach
aus wie so einen beutel vom sandmann
wir haben uns einen frischen orangen
tiere gekauft jeden tokio so jule was
für ein wunderschönes bauwerke also die
kathedrale auch aber ich habe mich
gerade hier dem bildschirm gesehen
sorry aber das ist 20 euro pro vier
stangen spargel und das hier kostet 37
euro
sie sind jetzt hier gerade am hyde park
angekommen ist dann frage ich habe mir
ein neues haus gekauft und da wohne ich
jetzt hier der hauskäufer so anstrengt
haben wir erst mal genetzt wir uns
gerade bürger besteht
ganz normal weil sie gerade nachgefragt
und stellen sich einfach nur heraus dass
in unserem zimmer eine person zu heiß
war und das heißt jetzt allerdings ja
auch von dem blogger ja so richtig
aufgestanden haben jetzt unsere sachen
hier schon mehr oder weniger alle fertig
gepackt und checken jetzt aus dem urteil
aus und fliegen zurück nach köln bei der
wochenendtrip weil wir unser einjähriges
zusammensein zelebriert haben das gerne
daumen hoch da wenn es euch gefallen hat
mal ist die überraschung geglückt ja
schon ein bisschen kontaktaufnahme
zimmer in köln
[Applaus]
[Musik]